hey everyone it's sarah with register
now sorry and calm and in this video i'm
going to go over some tips for drawing
blood as a nursing student nurse or even
a phlebotomist you will have to draw
blood as a nursing student you'll be
learning how to draw blood so in this
video i'm going to talk about why we
draw blood in the healthcare field give
you some tips on how to do this like
setting up your materials whether to use
butterflies or straight needles and I'm
going to go over the best spots for
drawing blood and I'm actually going to
show you on a person the veins that tend
to be the best for drawing and you can
where you can actually see those and
give you the proper names of those veins
then lastly I want to cover some
troubleshooting because sometimes
whenever you're drawing blood the blood
will quit coming out into your tube what
should you do and talk to you about some
things that sometimes happen so first
let's talk about why we draw blood okay
in the healthcare field doctors it is
like standard protocol every time a
patient comes in even if you go to the
clinic your doctor is going to order
blood work blood work tells me tells us
so much about a patient status for
instance it tells us their electrolyte
status how's their sodium their
potassium their calcium it tells us if
they are if they have a certain disease
it also tells us if they we can check
their drug levels say we came in and
they we think that they may be taken too
much of their antidepressant by accident
called lithium or something like that we
can see check that drug level so it
tells us so much about a patient so it's
really important that as a nursing
student nurse or phlebotomist that we
know how to do this efficiently so let's
go over some tips okay the very first
thing that I always had issues with at
first was getting the right tubes for
what the doctor order for instance each
tube has certain additives or maybe no
additives in it that certain labs go
into and a lot of hospitals or clean
wherever you work will have a chart that
will tell you what each ordered thing by
the doctor goes into for instance at
most facilities a CBC which is a
complete blood count will go in a purple
tube or your coax or coagulants will go
like pt/inr s will go in a blue tube so
you always want to make sure that you're
getting the right tubes before you go
draw blood because you don't want to be
in there you you work so hard to get
that vein you hit that vein draw your
blood and your nice little tubes and
then you send it to the lab and lab
calls you and says you sent us the wrong
tubes for what the doctor ordered this
isn't going to work you're going to have
to draw the blood again because you
don't want to go tell that patient I'm
going to draw your blood again because I
messed up it makes you look bad so
always make sure you're getting those
right tubes okay next whatever you're
first starting out make sure that you
are getting familiar with your equipment
Oh every place is set up differently
they have different equipment but
generally you have your selection on
what you can use needle wise I like to
use butterfly needles which I'll show
you what one looks like here in a second
versus the straight the butterfly
needles and it's like the needle and it
has two wings one on each side and you
can grip that as you go in to stick the
patient's thing and what's really great
about the butterfly the wings are great
but is that whenever you actually hit
that Bank you see a little flash of
blood and you know that you're in there
whenever I've used straight needles you
don't know if you hit the vein only how
you know is when you pop the to be on
the vacutainer and blood starts coming
out so I really recommend if you were
first starting out that you start with
these butterfly needles and here is a
picture of a butterfly needle the first
what you'll see and then you're going to
see another picture of someone actually
drawing blood on a patient and they're
using the straight needle and also known
that picture how there's a vacutainer
attached to that needle and then you
have the tube which is collecting the
blood
you
okay next I wanted you to pay attention
to that vacutainer in the previous
picture because whenever you're getting
familiar with this you need to know how
to properly unscrew on the vacutainer to
the tubing of the needle and as with the
butterfly if you notice that you had the
butterfly needle then you have this long
piece of tubing that's where your
vacutainer will screw on to and the
vacutainer actually what's in it looks
like this little rubber part but
whenever you pop that tube onto the
vacutainer there's a needle that goes
down into that tube and that's and the
suction from the tube causes the blood
to feel into the tube so get familiar
with how to hook that up and set it up
and also be sure you're grabbing the
right supplies you'll want to take
alcohol prep some goals with you a
tourniquet and your right tubes and get
the appropriate needle size you can pick
anywhere from a 20 to maybe a 23 to an
18 gauge whenever you're drawing blood I
generally whenever I'm drawing blood I
like to pick a larger needle if I have
lots of tubes to draw because sometimes
if you use a small smaller bore needle
the needle will actually claw it off
with the blood and then you'll have to
resit the patient so it's at your
discretion with what you want to use
okay let's talk about the best spots for
drawing blood whenever you're drawing
blood I like to go by feeling instead of
seeing the vein I in order to fill a
vein I really recommend if you're new
with this that you feel the veins on
yourself or another person with great
name take your index finger and just
find veins and the bend of the arm or in
the hand the bend of the arm is best
because you have some really good juicy
veins there which I'll go over here in a
second and you will get what a vein
feels like because once you understand
what a vein feels like you can tell that
it feels completely different than a
tendon a muscle or a nerve because
whenever I was first starting out that
was my thing I was like am i filling a
muscle or attendant is that a vein and
so I really a with all my practice
approaches all my husband just filling
veins and you just know like it just has
a certain
nice spongy feel to it and you know it's
a vein okay first let's talk about the
AC area which is called the antecubital
fossa area which is the inner elbow
now there's three veins that are really
great on this area and it's this area
right here and here in a second you're
going to see me feeling on a person
those veins but first let's go over
those veins real Hass and my favorite
vein that I absolutely love and most
full-body myths and nurses who draw
blood love is the media cubital vein it
is the vein right here in the middle and
you'll see it here in a second and then
also in this area you have the basilic
and the cephalic veins
those are the best for getting blood so
let's watch that video real fast of me
showing you about those veins okay I
want to show you real fast some popular
spots that people use when drawing blood
in the arm the number one spot that most
nurses and phlebotomist look is in the
antecubital area this is known as the AC
region it's the inner part of the elbow
and the first thing that most people
look for is the media cubital and it is
this vein right here that you see notice
it's in the middle of these veins
located over here this is a very popular
spot this is what I always go for it
first now if I can't find it also look
over here in this vein this is called
the basilic vein it starts up in this
area of the arm and branches off into
these accessory veins that's another
popular spot and then another spot is
also called the cephalic vein it starts
up here and branches down and this is
that vein that you see right here so
those are the three biggest spots that
most people use when drawing blood or
even starting IVs so let's go over the
veins in the hand
okay the next spot that we tend to look
at is the top of the hands and we
usually access the dorsal venous network
of veins and here to say you're going to
see a video of what those veins look
like whenever they're engorged up at the
top keep in mind in some patients these
veins are not ideal because they're
really pencil thin and they don't they
tend to blow and they're really fragile
but here is a
a video of someone who has really great
veins in their hand
okay real fast I'm going to show you the
hand veins some people have great hand
veins and some people's hand veins are
flat and you really can't see them now
here on this hand main on this hand you
see all these veins these are called the
dorsal venous network is just a network
of veins typically people will have
different sizes and different locations
of veins but the tip whenever you're
using these veins they really like to
roll like this so always get the person
to make a fist make it a little light
fist for me and see how it's straighten
up vein out and it'll keep it from
rolling whenever you go to stick it for
drawing blood and that will help you out
so I'm always first look in your
antecubital area and then look in your
hand area so that is just a little bit
about the hand bangs okay some things
you want to keep in mind whenever you're
using either the AC or the hand veins is
preventing a vein from rolling that's
one thing that really frustrates us
whenever we're trying to draw blood as
we go and we see we fill the vein and we
see it and then it just rolls to the
side once the needle penetrates the skin
so some tips on how to prevent that I
made a whole video on that you can see
on those videos down in the description
on teaching you how to prevent a rolling
vein I really go in depth with that but
just some side notes if you're going in
the AC and the veins are rolling extend
your arm out have the patient have the
patients in their arm out and that will
just keep the veins nice and straight
because when you bend it bend the arm
and you're trying to go in with the
needle the veins more likely to roll so
have them straighten the arm out next
and if you're going in the hand because
those hand Bains like to roll have them
make a fist and that will stabilize the
dein for you and another thing as a side
note if you have a patient who comes in
and those veins are already engorged
meaning that they're already puffed up
and they don't need a technically a
tourniquet don't use a tourniquet
because too much pressure on that vein
may cause it to blow and then you'll
have to stick them again so if you
already see the name and it's already
engorged don't put a tourniquet on you
really don't need one okay let's talk
about some troubleshooting
sometimes whenever you go in and you're
drawing blood you hit the vein and you
pop your tube on and you get some blood
and then all of a sudden it quits
flowing blood usually this is what's
happened either your needle has clotted
off now if this is like your second or
third or fourth tube that's probably
what's happened maybe you didn't use a
larger sized needle and the blood has
just collected in there and clotted off
or you're up against a valve and in my
that video those videos I was talking
about I was talk I've talked about valve
so you'll understand what those are but
sometimes what happens is whenever you
have a vein that bifurcates or branches
off and you stick the needle in
sometimes you hit this valve and it will
cause blood to quit coming pulling into
your tube and what I usually do it works
really great is if that happens to you
just barely slide the needle don't pull
it out of the skin but barely just move
the needle out around in the skin and
usually that'll have your blood start
coming back but sometimes that happens
and also if you notice say that another
thing that happens is that you get a
flash you know you're in the vein you
pop your tube on and nothing's coming
out at all but you know you're in the
vein usually what's happened is that
either your tube is bad maybe it was a
bad tube because sometimes that's
happened to me and I've popped on
another tube that I had with me and it
drew perfectly so either you had a bad
tube or you really needed to use a
tourniquet in this situation because the
tourniquet causes so much pressure and
causes that blood to jet out and you
don't have enough force on that vein to
allow the blood to come so and as
another side note if you didn't use a
tourniquet don't expect the blood to
just really jet out because you don't
have that pressure on it a little more
just come out slowly so those are things
that could happen while you're drawing
blood and just help you troubleshoot
hopefully to prevent you from having to
remove the needle and have to stick them
again so those are some tips on how to
draw blood please check out my other
videos on how to start IVs and how to
find veins and thank you so much for
watching and please consider subscribing
to this YouTube channel